it to another edition of Market takes
I'm your host dionma Bowen an exciting
but very interesting jobs report today
we are obviously breaking that down the
December non-farm payrolls report I'm
going to be digging into all that
explaining just what we saw in the
report what we learned and what this
means for the markets going forward
we're also going to talk about the
market reaction all that good stuff so a
lot to come here on Market takes but
before we do that I want to say I know
you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and I
appreciate you so thank you for tuning
in to Market takes uh look so we're
going to break down what the report said
get through all the numbers talk about
how it compared to expectations uh we're
also going to talk about obviously the
market reaction stocks bonds currencies
Commodities all that good stuff and what
that tells us about how investors are
breaking down and understanding this
report
um of course we're going to get into
understanding the fed and coming into
this report what the Federal Reserve
makes this report was really the most
important thing much more important than
what it says about the economy or what
it says about the future of jobs was how
the FED interprets this report and I
think there's some very interesting
reactions in the market that we can sort
of look to to see what investors think
about what the FED thinks about this
report
um of course we're also going to talk
about those investor expectations and
then you know I never leave you without
talking about what to look for next
because you know as investors we're not
looking backwards we're looking forward
even though we got the backwards looking
data so again thanks for tuning in to
Market takes I'm your host Dion Robert
Bowen let's get into it so first and
foremost the December job support showed
the U.S economy added 223
000 jobs in December the unemployment
rate falling to 3.5 percent now that's
usually just kind of a technical
indicator not something that a lot of
folks on the investment side watch but
this report showed some very strong
numbers we're going to talk a little bit
about that in just a minute now that 223
000 jobs added number was above the
expect station for two hundred thousand
so not a big beat you know we saw the
ADP report yesterday that showed 235 000
private jobs added that really sank the
market because folks were saying oh no
the fed's gonna have to do more we're
gonna have to see more rate increases
more rate hikes from the FED a tighter
economy longer for or stronger for
longer higher for longer all those
things uh this report was better than
expected but there were some details
within it which is why we got that
initial pop in the market stocks
initially jumped higher and then you're
seeing kind of a comeback right now so
I'm going to explain all that listen
2022 was a very strong year for job
growth employers added 4.5 million jobs
throughout the year this is the second
strongest year on record going back to
1940. so a lot of jobs added a strong
job growth year that's normally a good
thing however the stock market obviously
did not reflect that we saw big time
turndowns now the biggest piece of this
report report I thought and when you're
looking at the market reaction and when
you just kind of understand what's
really important what are the pieces to
dig through what are the details it was
this average hourly earnings number and
average hourly earnings is the thing
about you know how much wages are rising
and the FED has really signaled that out
as they say wages are rising too fast
that's not a sign of a strong healthy
economy that's a sign of an economy
that's going to keep being inflationary
that's going to keep pushing prices
higher we want that number to come down
we need the wage or we need the labor
market to get more in line with
traditional years of wage growth now the
average hourly earnings number missed it
was below expectations 4.6 percent
year-over-year growth and 0.3 percent
month over month that's lower than
expected that was expected to be five
percent year over year and expected to
be about 0.6 percent uh month over month
so that's actually lower from November
and November was even revised lower so
you're seeing what's not necessarily
good for folks who have jobs out there
who are trying to get that next job
we're trying to bolster their paychecks
and keep up with inflation but that is
good in terms of if you're an investor
looking at what the fed's looking at and
saying okay this wage growth is coming
down we've seen US inflation overall the
CPI Consumer Price Index has
consistently kind of come down since
that June Peak at nine percent and in
November it was at 7.1 percent so along
with inflation coming down we're seeing
that wage growth number come down
average hourly earnings now well below
five percent at five at four point six
percent that is a big time number now
when I we talk about that unemployment
rate 3.5 percent well that generally
came from good news we saw uh newly
unemployed a lot more folks coming into
the wage Force but a lot of folks who
were unemployed coming back unemployed
the the number of previous unemployed
people fell by 278 000 and new entrants
to labor force increased 439 000. so we
have not seen a lot of those folks
coming in from the sidelines as they say
folks who weren't looking for jobs jobs
before now looking for jobs looking for
employment and we are seeing that start
to pick up also a lot of those people
who were unemployed looking for jobs
they're finding jobs
and that is what's pushing down that
unemployment rate to three and a half
percent again near some of the lowest
levels it's been in the post-world War
II era it's a big deal so listen when we
when we talk about all this as we know
it's all about what the Market's telling
us and the Market's going to tell us a
lot about what the economy is going to
look like and what matters and what to
look for going forward so as we look out
of the economy I'm checking out wsj.com
right now the Dow is up 0.7 percent s p
about the same the NASDAQ of about 3.3
percent excuse me not three percent
point three percent uh you were seeing
initially stocks really jumped out after
that uh the job support jobs report came
out at 8 30. we saw the stock market
open at 9 30 just kind of went straight
up and then it came basically straight
down after that opening I think a lot of
folks kind of selling maybe seeing that
this report showed more jobs added than
expected keeping the trend in line with
what we saw from the ADP private
payrolls report yesterday as well as the
initial jobless claims report yesterday
okay those both showed less layoffs and
more hires than had been expected but
this report with that average hourly
earnings number stock investors are
saying okay maybe this gets the FED to
take their foot off the brake a little
bit the FED has really been stomping
hard pressing that break trying to get
the economy to slow down and now this
sort of changes the course of what are
the expectations for the fed's December
meeting or not the summer meeting excuse
me what are the fed's expected course
for the January meeting as well as
meetings through the rest of this year
and whether they need to raise it 50
basis points like they did last month or
con or you know maybe moving back down
to 25 basis points going at that level
that they raised rates at really over
modern history in the past 15 years
they have traditionally only raised
rates at 25 basis points remember we got
four increases of 75 basis points last
year and then another 50 basis point
rate hike in December so there was a
very clear bias by the FED to raise
rates significantly and keep them higher
that's what they've said they're going
to do well stock investors are kind of
excited because this report maybe gives
the FED an excuse and some of those
so-called Doves on the FED who are more
worried about unemployment who are more
worried about folks losing their jobs
and and more worried about the economy
being strong than they are about
inflation getting too high this gives
them some ammunition when they're in
those meetings when they're talking a
Fed chair Jerome Palestine hey hey look
at this average hourly earnings are down
average hourly earnings are coming down
exactly what we want to keep inflation
in check and that's the reason why maybe
we don't need to do too much when the
FED kind of relaxes lays back a little
bit the economy is able to grow more and
that really boosts the stock market
because folks are able to borrow more
money when you can borrow more money you
can put that money into stocks and stock
invest testers like that so the other
big piece of this though you got to talk
about bonds we got to talk about bonds
if you know me you know I love talking
about bonds the bond market is really
where we see the the true market if you
will you know the the smart money is
really in those bonds so as we look at
the 10-year yield that's the most traded
in the bond market we saw an initial you
know decline in yields which means
prices go up right so a lot of folks
were buying those bonds after this
report came out but since the report has
come out and since folks have had a
little bit more time to kind of analyze
and look into it you're seeing a little
bit of that come off and then boom right
straight down again as folks looked at
it even more so the 10-year now at about
3.63 and you're looking really across
the board the 10-year the seven year
five year all the way until you get down
to that three-month Bill and that was
the one place where we saw yields kind
of pick up which is the expectations for
immediate action by the Federal Reserve
folks saying look this isn't going to
deter the fed from raising rates
immediately and January maybe the first
quarter of this year at their meetings
but we think overall this sort of gives
them an excuse to maybe lay back maybe
do a little less maybe not raise rates
quite as much as they've tried to convey
and really the FED has said very clearly
we need for markets to not be buoyant we
need for rates to be lower we want the
stock market lower and when folks
respond in this way where they're buying
stocks they're pushing prices up they're
pushing bond prices lower and pushing
those yields higher that's the opposite
of what the FED wants
also when we're looking out at
Commodities I thought a very interesting
reaction was what we saw from oil prices
oil prices really picked up strongly up
about one and a half percent then
they've now cut that in half or a little
more crude Futures uh WTI and Brent are
up about 0.7.8 percent gold still up
strongly again a lot of these things
kind of shot up after the job support
and are now coming back down a little
bit silver still up about one and a half
percent a big move from Silver as we
look out at the currency Market the
dollar is down the Euro really took off
after that jobs report again showing
that average hourly earnings are coming
down that is an expectation now that
gives folk the expectation that the
Federal Reserve won't have to do as much
and when fed and when the FED doesn't
raise rates well that makes the dollar
less attractive makes other currencies
more attractive so the Euro really taken
off the Japanese Yen getting a boost uh
the British pound getting a boost all
these things not a huge move we're not
talking one two percent but a half
percent here and there all these
currencies have moved about a half
percent but all basically in the same
direction dollar down other Global
currencies going up and when you look
out at crypto let's see what we got
going on in the crypto Market well
crypto still down but really pretty flat
Bitcoin down about half percent ethereum
uh very little moved about up point zero
one percent on the day or down point
zero one percent so when I talk about
the Federal Reserve right we're talking
about the fed and Fed chair Jerome
Powell they have really been laser
focused on the labor market they haven't
talked much about corporate earnings
corporate profits corporations raising
their prices they've really talked about
Labor and when the FED does that what
they're saying is when more folks demand
raises when they're getting higher wages
for moving jobs things like that which
is what we saw throughout 2022 well then
corporations raise their prices they say
Hey you know our Our Workers are asking
for more money to make up for that we've
got to raise the prices and so the FED
has said listen as long as these average
hourly earnings are rising as long as
wages are increasing significantly and
much faster than our two percent Target
that's why we'll need to do more to try
and get the labor market back in check
one thing that's been really interesting
is that earnings those average hourly
earnings have not come even close to
inflation in CPI so as we saw CPI at
nine percent back in June we saw average
hour earnings about five percent and now
as we're seeing CPI at seven percent for
November we say we're seeing those
average hourly earnings at 4.6 so you're
still seeing a gap it's kind of lowering
as inflation overall comes down and gets
closer to that wage Target but wages are
still well below the level the overall
level of inflation now when we look at
the price or sorry not the price Target
but as we look at company margins
average profit margin for companies
that's the highest it's ever been
companies are making the most profit on
everything they sell when you look at
the uh the average profit margin number
on the S P 500 that's at about 13.
that's some of the highest levels we've
ever seen which means companies for
every dollar of sales that they do for
everything that they sell and they make
a dollar on they're getting about 13
cents in profit now that number changes
depending on wages depending on what
they're paying for inputs but what we
have seen is consistently the amount of
money that companies are making for
everything they sell has been rising
their their profit margins have been
increasing and a lot of folks have said
that's what's really the problem here
with inflation is that we're seeing
those profit margins rise and companies
are making a lot of money you've got a
lot of economists right now
folks from the left the right the center
people like Nobel Laureate Joseph
stieglitz Wharton Professor Jeremy
Siegel Economist at the right-leaning
American Enterprise Institute at the
left-leaning economic policy Institute
they're saying Hey listen the FED is
making a mistake they need to stop
raising rates so aggressively and
choking off the economy because they're
going to needlessly cause a recession
well the numbers that we got today
really kind of support that you know
what wages are starting to come down
they're not coming down super fast
they're still much higher than the fed's
two percent Target but 4.6 wage gains
compared to seven percent inflation
you're you're still not really winning
and when you look at real wages real
wages actually decreased all of last
year 2022 because they were far below
the rate of overall inflation so that's
why folks were looking so much at this
jobs report because the Federal Reserve
has said it's jobs jobs are the problem
wages are the problem people are
increasing their wages there are too
many unfilled jobs for the number of
jobs out there it's almost two to one
for a while it actually had been two to
one there were two job openings for
every unemployed person here in the
United States and the FED had said
that's a problem because that's going to
keep wages going higher we saw the jolts
report earlier this week that showed
that there is there have been an
increase in job openings a decrease in
the number of people hired that means
that those jobs are still there's less
competition for those jobs which means
employers have to pay up which means
they'll pay more which means inflation
can keep rising up higher this has been
the big thing that really we've talked
about in terms of looking out at the
labor report looking at the labor market
excuse me and looking at this jobs
report
investor expectations have been for the
FED to raise rates this first quarter as
they've said then kind of keep them high
through the second quarter and then a
lot of investors are saying either
inflation is going to start coming down
and the fed's going to cut rates or the
U.S is going to enter a recession in the
second half of the year or late in the
year and the FED is going to have to cut
rates in order to deal with that now Fed
chair Palace said very clearly I'm not
going to cut rates uh we need to keep
rates High because inflation is my
number one target you know my idol is
former Fed chair Paul volcker who raised
it who raised U.S interest rates all the
way up to 18 19 percent in order to beat
back inflation put the country through a
painful recession that's what Jerome
Palestinian wants to do you've got these
economists saying you don't need to do
that and now with this jobs report today
well that's another little bullet in the
gun of some folks who say you don't need
to do all that so listen that's the big
picture of what we're looking at with
this job support it really is all about
that average hourly earnings number and
we'll see if there continues to be some
bullish momentum because that does kind
of fly in the face of what the FED has
been saying they've said we're going to
keep rates High because we think that
rate that earnings and wages are too
high we need to get them back towards
two percent 4.6 isn't really that close
to two percent but it's down from five
percent and it's well below the overall
rate of inflation so listen here's what
you need to look out for coming up next
we've got the employment Trend index
report coming out on Monday now that's
not something a lot of investors watch
closely but it's something the Federal
Reserve will certainly be looking at
look at that number investors want to
see this number continue to fall it's
been falling over the past few months
and if it falls again that could be
really good news you could see a pop in
the market
um also we've got the November consumer
credit report that is already at a
record high that was a record high for
2022 we'll see if 2023 Americans stop
taking on more credit less you know if
they keep taking on credit card debt
keep borrowing money from the banks
personal loans all that because it's
really starting to get to a level where
credit card interest rates are always at
the highest they've been uh mortgages
are some of the highest they've been in
15 years so do people keep taking on
more credit borrowing more money because
that's going to really leverage Folks up
and if the economy takes a turn it could
be a problem and of course CPI the
Consumer Price Index that is going to be
very closely watched especially after
this jobs report we will be right here
on Market takes breaking that down for
you telling you all about it so be here
with us on Thursday don't be a
that's a square don't do it uh we will
be here on Thursday Market takes I hope
you'll join us listen that's going to do
it for me I am Dion rabone your host
here on Market takes thank you so much
for being with us we're going to wind it
down now I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you were here
with me and again I appreciate that
thanks a lot for being with us right
here on Market takes